do you have any dresses that you know
you're not gonna wear as a dress anymore
but they'd look cute as a shirt because
i saw this on tiktok this is the dress
that i'm gonna use it has a zipper in
the back too
i have
this dress i also have this dress this
is like the perfect dress to do this too
because i like how it fits up top but it
doesn't fit over what i got going miss
man back there i really actually love
this dress but i don't love how it fits
on the lower half of my body but i think
it would make a really cute shirt so
okay first get a body suit that you like
the fit of okay so in order to do this
you're gonna need one of your favorite
bodysuits for like
how it fits grab your scissors a pair of
fabric scissors and something to mark it
with i'm gonna use this purple marker
and lay the dress out put the bodysuit
over it but make sure that the armpits
line up everything above it doesn't
matter and just to be safe because i'm
not sewing it i'm gonna put a fingers
width in between where this ends and
where i want to mark it and then trace
all the way down this is what it should
look like when you cut it this is what
you get i'm sure you can put like snaps
on it but i just took i'm gonna try to
put snaps so
we'll see how that goes and this is what
it looks like tucked
it's really scary to cut something that
you want spent money on but i feel like
i'm repurposing it right although this
feels very wrong
i feel like it's for the best
right
for all intense purposes
that looks like a bodysuit does that not
look like a bodysuit to you
because it looks like a body suit to me
that bottom the bottom of that is
rough but
i feel like it's gonna work
now i'm gonna try it with a pink dress
i'm very nervous for this dress because
it's like ruched here and i don't really
know how that's gonna work i'm not
planning on ever wearing this again so
if i ruin it then it's fine i feel like
i would way more likely wear this as a
shirt way more than i would have ever
worn it as a dress look at the bottom of
this it's not great it's not that bad i
have these which are the snaps
and then these
this is supposed to explain to me how
how to do it i
oh this is actually super easy oh my god
i'm gonna be putting buttons on
everything now i'm gonna be so excited
look
this it's like a legitimate bodysuit now
now one thing i will say is if you
decide to make it into a bodysuit the
way i did make sure that the bottom
pieces that clip together are long
enough mine might be a little too short
and they're really up there wait for it
to snap
okay
we're gonna go try these on with jeans i
am so excited
to see if these work
are you ready it works folks
it works
let's see how the other one looks 10 out
of 10 recommend turn your dresses into
shirts if you're not going to wear it
anymore you don't like the way it fits
turn it into a shirt
10 out of 10 recommend
[Music]